is a law professor at the university of
gdansk in poland he happens to be in
budapest hungary right now and that's
where he joins us from thank you
professor for taking out the time to
speak to us now uh we understand that
poland's government has been
restructuring the judiciary for years
critics have long complained that judges
are being put under pressure
with this verdict that we are seeing
right now
is that a result of government pressure
uh
well thank you thank you for having me
and uh let us be very clear about some
uh fundamental uh uh things that are uh
at stake here first of all there is no
uh there is no uh conflict between uh
polish constitution and the eu treaties
secondly uh the court so-called court
that has
rendered this decision is not really a
court because it has been staffed with
uh judges that should have never been
elected to the court because there were
no vacancies and then the president of
the court uh is not really a president
because she has been uh elected in clear
violation of the polish constitution but
uh those are three points that we we
really have to bear in mind but there's
more fundamental uh issue that
underlines all
all this post-war europe has been based
on one uh fundamental uh principle that
uh every political power must be a
constrained power and to constrain power
and to hold political power to account
you need independent institution that
was the founding myth of the european
integration and constitutional courts
were always to play a pivotal role in
making sure that every political power
is a
constrained power in this case we have
the opposite we have a situation where
uh a court that is staffed with illegal
judges
is rubber stamping whatever the
government uh deems necessary for
uh uh
pushing uh with its uh with its own
agenda so the court does not make it
more difficult for the uh political
power does not keep the political power
in check but rather it's a shameless
enabler of whatever is decided by the
political majority of the day so let me
be very clear the future of european
integration is at stake and our own i
mean our own polish presence and
participation in the european uh
institutions and the european
communities at stake as well professor
let's talk about that because the eu now
says that it is analyzing the situation
and already the word uh poll exit is
making uh the rounds here in all
different capitals uh poland's exit from
the eu how do you see this standoff
playing out
well i i used the temple exit five years
ago when i first analyzed the steps that
were taken by the polish government in a
biological forest in eastern poland
where poland for the first time uh
declined to follow the order made by the
european court of justice uh in 200 2017
and the writing was on the wall already
at that time
right now we simply have a culmination
of the process that has been going on
for five years
and for five years basically the
european commission has been uh sitting
idly sitting uh and watching what has
been transpiring inviting polish
government to uh a more uh dialogue hope
hoping for a fruitful conversations
about the rule of law crisis uh so uh
let me use the metaphor the rome has
been burning and uh the commission has
been playing uh
fiddles so uh right now it's pretty much
too late to do anything meaningful
because uh uh the house has been burned
already so uh there's no independent
judiciary there is no independent
constitutional court the entire
structure of the state has been captured
by the uh
government uh
as it is uh constituted now so uh it's
it's really it's really uh heartbreaking
for me to say this but i don't know
what's next uh poll exit might be the
only the only option left because if you
really want to fall in line with what
this body decided yesterday you you the
government uh have to take paul poland
out of the eu altogether
thomas tadeusha konsevic a law professor
at the university of gdansk in poland
thank you very much for sharing your
insights with us
thank you
you